we continue talking food with some
delicious options for back-to-school
lunches chef
jeff from smith's the sponsor of this
next segment shows us more
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's okay so it's that time of year
that every kid dreads and every parent
loves it's back to school time and what
i'm going to do today is show you some
ideas with school lunch and everything
that you can do
millions of possibilities but first
smith is offering a great donation
opportunity that deals with the
zero hunger zero waste program that they
do and that is the cash flows
cashiers will be asking for a dollar
fifty donation and that donation
gets you these little lunch kits that go
to kids in need so it's a great
opportunity
to provide those meals for kids okay
past that we're gonna show you some cool
ideas that you can do
first of all you can find a ton of
different
lunch ideas lunch boxes all over smith
this time of year and they're all on
sale which makes it even better but
let's get to the food part
so a couple ideas that i had you can buy
these bento boxes
at your local smiths and they fit into
the lunch boxes nowadays but
one of the things i like to do is the
homemade lunchable and that's just
some crackers that you get some little
cheese slices
maybe get some ham or whatever and slice
that up just however kids like it
healthy your kids are going to love it
the next one i have is we're gonna make
a kebab
and so what i did is i made a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich and i have a
couple of different fruit items
i have some kebab sticks but make sure
to cut that sharp end off we don't want
the kids
injuring themselves with it if you have
popsicle sticks that's probably a better
option even
but anyways let me show you how i
assemble that
take a peanut butter sandwich get some
cheese on there
maybe a grape another sandwich
strawberry but you get you get the idea
whatever your child loves but that's a
fun way to get the the sandwich and all
those healthy things
kids are going to love that okay the
next one is the quesadilla
quesadillas can be made just like a
regular sandwich in fact in this one i
have just some shredded cheese and some
ham
and they can be in cold too which is
another great part about them so i made
this quesadilla ahead of time
let me just cut it into some slices
and then let that cool off and just put
it in your kids lunch box
like so and they're gonna love that and
they have these awesome little guacamole
kits that you can buy
and throw that in there with some some
chips
okay and then also let's go ahead and
just add a little bit more fruit here
because can't go wrong with more fruit
right i guess the point i'm trying to
make is
the kids lunch doesn't have to be boring
and there's a million opportunities
not only to donate to the no hunger or
zero hunger
zero waste program but to give your kids
a lot of fun options with their school
lunches it just that doesn't have to be
boring you can do fun things
there's lunch boxes and uh as you can
see from my display there are a million
different ideas and i probably could
have done way
much more either way
there's so many opportunities you can
find at your local smith so
thank you so much for watching you guys
thank you for shopping take care of your
kids and those kids in need
and we will see you all next time
bye-bye
your kids and kids need great message
all right thank you smith's food and
drug for sponsoring this segment they
have over 30 locations in the valley
they're all over the place for more
you can visit smithfoodanddrugs.com